everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today were going to be
going of a trap called the budapest trap
and it starts out with pawn to d4 Knight
to f6 and then Knight to d2 now this is
a pretty in common move but I came
across the trap and thought that I
wanted to go over it a lot of people ask
me you know Kevin wall I'm playing you
know my opponents are making mistakes
but I don't know how to you know
capitalize on those mistakes can you
give me some ideas on you know when a
weaker player is playing something how
to capitalize on that so I feel like one
of the the first things I want to talk
about is this move right here so
obviously white would actually like to
play a move you know
Knight to c3 you know Knight to f3 some
of them move trying to control the
center but his knight that D to here is
actually blocking off that only his
Queen on d1 but also his bishop here on
c1 from development and it's really not
controlling the center like he he would
like to who'd actually like to not only
control you know this efore c4 but he
would actually like to bring you know it
to let's say c3 where he control this e4
and this d5 not only controlling his own
square but also attacking his potential
square of his opponent but you may see
an opponent play Knight to d2 and the
trap we're going to be going over today
is when you play pawn to e5 if you're
familiar with the budapest gambit at all
it typically arises from this moving
your knight to f6 and then you're going
to sacrifice this pawn here on e5 and
then you're going to use all your
Knights - to counter-attack that and try
to get that material back so after the
pawn takes on e5 black's going to now
play Knight to g4 now I do want to go
over some of the variations that you may
see any time I go over trap I do like to
go over what happens if they don't fall
for the trap
but first I do want to go over what the
trap is just in case someone wants to
see the trap and then stop watching the
video so the trap is any time you have a
night here on g4 it seems to be you know
everyone feels like they have to play
you know pawn to h3 it could be a bishop
here it could be a knight here but they
just feel like they have to play pawn to
h3 very common move that I see a lot
especially in blitz games from here all
blacks going to play is Knight to e3 now
if what excuse me if white takes here on
e3 then it's going to be checkmate if he
does not take then he's obviously going
to be losing his queen so he can choose
if he wants to lose his queen or check
me either way it's going to be a very
very easy win for black now if he does
take with this pawn here on e3 then
black can come in and play Queen to h4
check the only move that white has is
pawn to g3 and then Queen captures on g3
and checkmate so this is the budapest
trap it's a fantastic trap especially if
you can actually play it on someone
again this is only six moves so pretty
cool trap if you can actually lay it on
someone now again I do want to go over
variations if they don't actually fall
for the trap because h3 is obviously a
huge mistake but just kind of want to
show you the even if they don't play h3
you can still have a very very playable
playable game so from here white can do
one of two things he can give the
material right back to you which
obviously if your equal in material you
should be fairly decent as far as you
know a good game but if he does decide
let's say he plays Knight to f3 again
trying to control the center of the
board and he's defending his pawn on e5
black can now play Knight to c6 same
thing trying to control the suit of the
board and he's also adding another
attacker on this pawn to e5 now wide if
you wanted to just going over again he
can always give that back this material
on e5 but if you want to you could play
Knight to c4 trying to hold on to this
pawn here black can now play Bishop to
c5 again critical Square for black any
time if he can get his dark square
Bishop here attacking this weakness on
f2 for white here again he has two
attackers here his knight on d4 and his
Bishop on c5 attacking this weakness on
that too
so for here you know white can always
play
pawn to e3 trying to mitigate that
attack here and then black can just play
Queen to e7 so as you can see why it's
going to be giving back this material
black just has too many attackers on
this pawn on e5 why it's not going to be
able to hold on to that so even if even
if white does not fall for the trap and
play pawn to h3 which if he does it
feels pretty good to lay this trap on
someone but even if they don't you're
still going to have a very good game if
you've played the budapest game but
before you know a lot of variations for
black a lot of surprises that you can
actually lay on your opponent so as far
as material you're going to be okay even
though you do give up that pawn early on
it's going to be very hard for white to
hold on to that so just a few thoughts
hope you guys enjoy this trap video I'll
see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching